there are there there are elements on
the left groups like media matters for
instance
that will just pump out fake news and
youtube just says yes
so you know uh we we we had a media
matters wrote about us recently
claiming that because jack murphy who
was on the show
said donald trump gave concrete examples
of voter fraud
he didn't say donald trump gave proof he
said examples of
some i believe that's what he said maybe
i'm i'm getting wrong they claimed that
we were pushing this information
and then demanded youtube demonetize the
content
so the the the show is still monetized
but the fact that they're trying to go
after us simply because we're talking
about what trump said
is is a level of depravity you don't see
from the right to the left
the right isn't going after the left and
calling corporations to get them
stripped and removed because they don't
believe in it maybe
they used to the right they definitely
did media is more focused on the way
things look
that their that their listeners or their
viewers uh their viewers
actually learn by watching whereas
conservative
people learn by listening and so that's
why they're drawn to more radio
and you see like rachel maddow with her
her perfect posture and and done up hair
and like
it's all they call him the orange man
like they're talking about the way he
looks
but so it's less about i think that's
interesting um
observation that might be something to
the way people learn
maybe the left tries to claim that talk
radio succeeded on the right because
people on the right are dumb and just
follow the leader
and so you'd get a bill o'reilly or a
conservative personality and then they
would just
you know cluck along following i don't
think that's true i think that's
actually the left the left turns on cnn
and accepts it all as
law as if it's true and then you can see
how the guardians like
my pillow guy pushes you know martial
law when we don't even know what's on
those papers
like we don't know why it says that for
all we know it says invoking martial law
in the event
and then the part that's missing says
something happens would be really bad
and we should never do that
we don't know what the remainder of that
sentence is all about what it looked
like whereas like james o'keefe it's all
about what you hear
well another element to really kind of
comprehend here is that
when someone is trying to silence people
they don't have the moral high ground
so when you have examples by media
matters we're also seeing other reports
right now
of cnn and nbc news new york times
trying to go after
signal and other encrypting messaging
apps when we see alexandria
ocasio-cortez talking about we need to
ban polar we need to put people on list
we need to censor the internet we need
to rein
in the media we're seeing individuals
who are so
scared of ideas of them being challenged
with
just words sounds that they have to
punitively
silence and make sure that those ideas
don't even get discussed or even
thought about they're at such a point in
in their life where they want to control
what you can even think so when you're
coming from that point of view and
you're surrounding yourself with the
the biggest apparatuses of the police
state when
just a couple weeks ago you were totally
apprehensive against the police state
now they're surrounding themselves with
what is it 25 000
armed troops that have shoot to kill
orders that are transferring washington
dc into a fortress
when you have those kind of larger
institutional powers
fomenting themselves fortifying
themselves in
you really have something to to worry
about and consider moving forward that's
why i said they're not playing by any
rule set
no they're just like oh the cops are all
bad and then once the cops aren't
arresting trump supporters are like the
cops are our friends well it's a
you really don't want to do violence
against the government i think it's an
example of why because it freaks out the
politicians and then they surround
themselves with 25 000
shoot to kill cops well it depends who's
committing who's committing the violence
who
wh what political cause is behind the
violence people that storm the capital
that's one example but there's other
examples of entire police departments
being sieged
there's there's other events of of
buildings being lit on fire
people inside of them there was other
events where people got shot and killed
uh during the middle of protest just a
couple weeks ago that
i would say that's political violence
there was political violence the only
problem is it was
called out by the right wingers when it
was happening on the left
but when it's happening on the right
it's called that by right ringers and
left-wingers rightfully so but it should
always be called out because when you
use
violence politically everyone loses and
you're destroying the dialogue
that could prevent it there are there
are some people who would prefer to live
in a mad max style world
like there some there are some people
that want to watch the world burn
and there are some people that genuinely
believe if i can't have it no one can
and they'd rather burn it all to the
ground than lose the [ __ ] that's crazy i
don't think that's true
that people believe that they don't
think they sound really people maybe
they fantasize the
i don't think any who would want to just
struggle i'm not saying
the majority but they exist it's not
about destruction you know people like
that
have you have like have you been reading
the news and following social media well
you hear
like like uh you met people what do you
call it like
um hyperbole but i've never met anyone
like that that
if you the way i describe it is when you
open twitter just
picture a guy screaming at half of as
long as twitter is you just scroll
through everyone
[Music]
there are people on the left and the
right there are people on the right who
are saying
they will not there was a voicemail left
this guy got arrested
leaving a voicemail saying that they
will never allow a democrat to go into
these buildings and that
they would do some really really bad
things i can't repeat
do you know what happens if there's an
actual civil war it is
look look at aleppo you guys ever see
the photos of before and after in aleppo
it's
down in syria beautiful city after the
war
rubble and death dude if there was a
real civil war
they would be targeting laser targeted
drone strikes on houses
like they know where you live do not go
to war with the us government
it's it's it's not about the u.s not go
to war with because the us government is
backing them
a civil war is two factions fighting
over control of one government
or in some definitions factions trying
to leave or split a government
it's not like there's three factions
there's the establishment and the
populist left and the populist right
we don't exactly know what's going to
happen but elements of the military and
elements of law enforcement are being
split among
the left tribe and the right tribe lines
so it's not going to be laser drone
strikes it's going to be
it would literally be military fighting
military or
people just fighting people but i also
think we need to consider when we talk
about this
is the generations of warfare we're not
in that you know look we don't fight
with swords anymore we don't fight with
bows and arrows
i mean i guess you still kind of could
use a compound bow in warfare it's
probably effective in certain guerrilla
war tactics but for the most part war
changes
you know i love that saying from fallout
the video game war never changes it
actually changes a whole lot
the weapons change but the way stays we
used to hit each other with fists
then rocks then we we made swords and
clubs
and then we got horses then we got you
know guns then we got missiles and then
we've escalated over and over again and
now we're in propaganda and information
warfare
so the point i'm trying to make is i see
the comments on social media
from people who are saying they would
rather
conflict chaos blown up buildings and
all that if it means
they don't give up and and they and you
know their ideology persists or whatever
but that's why it's so important to push
back non-violently
i mean the whole even talking about
civil war makes me uncomfortable because
it does i think
inspire some of the crazies and they do
exist i i
don't i agree like they're not the
largest sum by any means it's probably
less than a half of a percentage point
but they do cause a lot of the problems
and so we have to figure out a way to
address it i think it is
condemning it well most of the people
calling for it have never really seen
conflict when you look at the a lot of
people who did
see warfare who saw people trying to
kill each other and saw people
die that's the last thing that they want
they're haunted by it they have ptsd and
a lot of these
vocal you know proponents a lot of these
most violent voices
or voices that have never been in combat
don't even know what it is
and it needs to be called out because
again we all lose once that happens well
and and stop
talking about things as if we're
currently in a war because we usually
hear some of that
on the left and it's coming from the
anti-cop folks who
are claiming we're at war with the
police they're shooting us in the middle
of the street like
no we can have reasonable conversations
about police reform if you'd like but
let's not pretend
that cops are just roaming the streets
of whatever city you're in and they're
just randomly shooting people that's
obviously not happening
so when people talk like that it does
again it's sort of that self-fulfilling
prophecy like i feel like they're
pushing in a direction where
we shouldn't want to go they're not
doing it for that purpose they're doing
it to win
arguments well let's look at this this
is my criticism of aoc
you know we can criticize trump for his
you know bombastic nature
but what aoc is saying right now is
absolutely inflaming everything
i've been saying for the past you know a
couple weeks now we everyone needs to
calm down
meditate go read a book go to nature
stay with your loved ones and even a
month or two before that
stay home make money that was something
mike cernovich said i agreed with like
now's the time
to ever for everybody everyone to chill
but there's a reality to this
i i know a lot of people don't like
hearing the phrase civil war
but what would you call it when you have
escalating street battles for several
years
one one group one partisan group using
every legal apparatus at their disposal
to remove the president
ultimately now still trying to and then
it culminates with a year of mass
writing across the country defended by
one
by proponents of one political faction
now you have
proponents of one other political
faction storming the us capitol building
so what you know i think we're
absolutely on that ground
it's certainly conflict we're definitely
not civil war we're at a cultural war
right and there is a hundred percent
there's one when would it be a civil war
a civil war would be a little bit more
uh engaged with both sides i mean
we should not pretend that both the
right and the left are doing it
at equal levels as far as you know
manpower for example
and we're not seeing it widespread on
both sides
and i do think that that is a part of
the issue and there's also
there's i don't know if we could say
that there is an ideal
yet that both sides are fighting for
versus a person they're fighting against
i think there's certainly elements
definitely on the left where they've got
ideas that they're fighting for uh on
the right i
don't know that yet no they're fighting
against they're fighting against other
ideas potentially but again the fighting
is not really happening
from the right here's the main issue
i'll put it this way as i've often put
it
if this does develop into full into
full-scale hot conflict
then in 50 years they will describe the
moments of january 6 as
well into the civil war meaning we can
go way back
to the berkeley riots where you know
antifa showed up
and were were bashing old trump
supporters throwing explosives at him
so when i saw that stuff i say i usually
say like this if everything were to stop
right now and de-escalate people would
say there wasn't a civil war
if it does continue to escalate then we
are absolutely in a civil war right now
one faction just stormed the capital
with the
misguided and rather absurd attempt at
some kind of
shutting down of the of the electoral
vote count process
the people are saying it on on these
videos that are getting released now
more and more videos are coming out
and they're saying things like where's
the count happening you know there's
only one of them
there's it's only one person we can stop
when there's thousands of us one video
where a lady is giving instructions
about where the senate chambers are and
how to get there
if you get to the point where you have a
political faction
storming into the capitol building to
subvert
the the political process that's
literally
the borderline definition of what civil
war is if it's inspired by delusion
do you count it as civil yes because
everybody thinks their dictator is right
everybody thinks their leader is the is
the glorious leader
you look at things that would happen you
look at what happened and i'll tell you
the
the main difference the difference
between
the rise of a dictatorship in a civil
war is whether or not one side is armed
and prepared to fight back
so you look at communist china the the
communists just abused and obliterated
and murdered and and destroyed
you look at world war ii germany there
was a lot of fight
fighting between factions in weimar
germany but ultimately
the communist socialists fled because
the legal system
uh at least a certain degree i'm reading
now many of these you know people in in
government really liked them
they prefer the nazi party over the
communists if you come now to where
we're at now it could possibly be there
won't be a civil war
because the left controls the cultural
establishment and uh you know
basically the entirety of the federal
government except for the you know
uh supreme court for now if it just goes
that direction
and conservatives just eventually get
steamrolled then no one's gonna call it
a civil war
now jason i would agree with you we're
not in you know a civil war a lot of
people use that kind of language
hyperbolically to also get clicks we
have to understand that but
we have to understand uh the future wars
are fought not with bullets
tanks or guns they're fought with
subversion indoctrination
influence and when we look at the term
fifth generational warfare i think there
is something to consider
about what is happening culturally what
is happening
through social media what is happening
on the mainstream media on hollywood
that is having an effect that in in part
is leading to i believe a larger
conflict
maybe it's a conflict of ideas but those
ideas are
paramount when it comes to the future of
our children the future of this country
and them turning out to be individuals
that
are self-harming self-defeating and and
people who
you know destroy themselves internally
through their bad actions that are
promoted
so that's something also to kind of
largely consider here
and if you were a strategic kind of
enemy
what would you rather do would you
rather have a hot war where you have
whether it's blood
whether it's gore there's there's so
much violence or
would you rather have a war where you
don't even have to shoot a gun
so that's something also worth
considering i have the university of san
diego
article from dr wasim ahmad qureshi
fourth and fifth generation warfare
technology and perceptions
and they basically talk about in in
fourth generational warfare it's
it's the blowing of lines between
politics and you know uh
and conflict and civilians so a lot of
people describe what we've been going
through as fourth generational war
because of the low intensity
conflict and violence things like antifa
smashing windows burning things down
spray painting you know
things about liberals but what we're
actually fully entrenched in
is coming off of fourth generational
warfare and moving
heavily into fifth generational warfare
so fifth generational warfare is
manipulation perception
information propaganda etc like luke was
just saying
there was a reason why in the past you
used force against somebody
because you had no other means to gain
control of a region or a group of people
or a resource
today it's extremely easy propaganda and
manipulation that's why tick-tock is so
dangerous
controlled by chinese interests and
influencing our young people
telling them what to think and feel and
what to do and it works
so right now you have online one side
clearly losing in every respect
they're losing physical fights now don't
get me wrong the proud boys
you know have beaten up antifa pretty
badly and some of them got a prison for
it
but if you look at the amount of damage
antifa has done and black lives matter
has done
they've caused massive damage across
this country while symbolically storming
the capital was probably the worst thing
we've seen yet there's way more
institutional
and so and damage to the general public
of this country caused by the left in
black lives matter
so in terms of how much we are seeing
the left push
substantially more 80 20 80 of the of
the pushing in the conflict is coming
from the left
cultural institutions including news
media almost entirely dominated by the
left right now
they frame everything as though the
right is bad the right
being banned left and right and all they
do is beg
their establishment conservative you
know establishment republicans
to repeal 230 or something which never
happens and won't happen
so ultimately what happens is in my
opinion republican politicians are too
stupid to realize what's happening
around them and thus
they're now having their constituents
purged they will no longer be able to
win a battle of ideas in the fifth
generational conflict
because they sat back and sat on their
hands and did nothing the left was
fighting a fifth generational war while
conservatives were just sitting there
saying like well now let's have a
conversation
about it when you nationalize elections
well but when you look at the house
results for example i mean the democrats
were supposed to win a whole bunch of
house
seats and they didn't quite the opposite
and i think that
you know that goes to certainly the
rural
versus urban city divide and it's
definitely a right versus left at that
point but i do think the closer you get
to the people
in most of the country the republicans
tend to do better
when facing the crazy on the left now
when it's both
moderates going or perceived as
moderates going up against each other
then it really is
that's local but think about aoc saying
they're all white supremacists and nazis
and then raising millions of dollars and
getting 12 million followers
lies work and the conservatives aren't
playing on the same battlefield they're
getting wiped out kind of reminds me of
the 60s
like nixon had the well linden b johnson
had the
the left of the 60s was like the
military military-industrial complex
using the media and back then they had
just television and they used it to
manipulate they had project mockingbird
that was like the cia was
paying and extorting these media
companies to pass their lies
and manipulation and the hippies and the
black panthers
were just subverted and they were
totally pressed and beaten down kind of
like you would say the right as being
right now they were organizing but they
couldn't contend with that media
and i just read 40 people died in the
civil rights movement 41 people so it
was
we would never call that a civil war
ever no one's ever even thought to
i've never thought to refer to that era
as a civil war it was just
unrest it was like what we're going
through now i that's what i see
now yeah but i i guess that was
still remnants of the actual civil war
you still had
the democrats for the most part up until
a certain point
being the party of the clan and jim crow
and the racists
so it was almost like it never ended
this is the crazy thing you know i just
i'm
watching that new movie just came out
have you seen it news of the world
mm-hmm
if you've heard of it uh i watched about
half of it so far and it's
good you didn't like it well i'm halfway
through and i'm entertained i'm not
going to pretend it's the greatest movie
in the world but it's interesting
because
uh tom hanks he plays a former
confederate soldier in texas
and you've got union soldiers in texas
and you can hear the rhetoric from the
the local you know southerners how they
feel about the north
and what really drives their anger and
it's interesting to see this movie
highlight these people are saying rich
northerners trying to force us you know
to tell us how we have to live and what
we have to do obviously civil war was
very much about slavery
but there was a lot a big element of
that's not too dissimilar to what's
happening today
but anyway the reason i bring it up is
in some ways the civil war never ended
you know this is the crazy thing
reconstructed and reconstruction ended
in 1876 when there was this hotly
contested
uh battle over the presidency and
opposing electors
we were sent to dc and they didn't know
what to do so they elected a panel
to just basically negotiate what was
going to happen to avoid the outbreak of
the civil war again
and what they decided basically was to
end reconstruction and they would give
the republican the presidency
from there you ended up with the clan
these elements still existed they still
fought
it made its way into the civil rights
movement and now we have something weird
and different but it's still
the tribes and the cultures are so
dramatically different
in these big cities in california in new
york and chicago versus in southern
cities and southern states but more
importantly the urban versus rural
divide is extremely profound and
dramatic
and you've got because of the internet
the ideological split becoming
more and more extreme maybe the reality
is there's elements
of what this country went through that
never went away
and it constantly keep getting seated in
some fashion in different ways
or maybe it's just this country is way
too big and people in different states
want to live in different ways
so someone in new york trying to pass a
law and how people in west virginia got
to live that's not going to fly with
people in west virginia
they're like i mean there's a whole
guiding principle behind states rights
but it's being ripped away it is but
that's why we have elections and i i
don't believe that
these elections are a lost cause for
republicans i think
in two years we're going to see that
shift and historically we tend to
i think in two years the republicans are
going to be
much more progressive well another thing
to kind of realize here that the base of
the republicans is being wiped out
whether through opioids obesity
self-hate
suicide self-harm the flyover states are
affected by
those things more than a lot of the city
areas and when you look at the
the base it they're slowly but surely
killing themselves off in many instances
especially with the high suicide rate so
that's
awesome i kind of like to think they're
actually being strangled out by these
these trade agreements set up by
namely democrats where they took many of
these manufacturing plants and sent them
overseas
trump was one of the reasons why
actually i should stop there and say the
koch brothers and republicans were very
much in favor for a long time as well
i think that's why you get donald trump
because he said to these people in these
in these places where the factories have
been ripped away i'm going to
renegotiate for you
i'm going to fix this problem that's
what people wanted
so i look at a lot of these towns i i
spent a lot of time looking at dying
towns
because i was thinking of like where can
we move and set up a studio with good
internet
that actually has some infrastructure
and it's it's sad to see i read about a
bunch of different cities
in you know in middle america that were
once thriving and the factory got sent
to mexico factory guys into china and
now their population's in rapid decline
people are dying
when people have no purpose is when they
die i was reading there's a documentary
on blue zones
people who live over 100 in like high
numbers and one of the things they
mentioned is that when people
retire that's like the most likely time
of death for a person is it right after
they retire
because they no longer have a purpose
they're not doing anything they're
wasting away
so we've seen with covet especially
people sitting at home
they're just wasting away they're
getting out of shape their blood
is getting really bad and they're like
you know atrophying
getting depressed a lot of suicides so
you know i don't know long story short
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm
so come back to check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also
available on all podcast platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all next time